تحظى العائله الملكيه البريطانيه باهتمام
كبير لعده قرون وخاصه في عهد الملكه
الراحله الثانيه التي كانت تتمتع بحب جزء
كبير من رعاياها واحترامهم لها ونجحت في
الحفاظ على شعبيه عائلتها واهميتها بالرغم
من الفضائح والخلافات التي هزت النظام
الملكيه في السنوات القليله الماضيه
اعتقد ان العائله المالكه لا تزال محوريه
في كل ما هو مرتبط بمفهوم بريطاني ومن
المهم جدا ان تعرف ان المؤسسه الملكيه مرت
باختبارات الزمن ولا زالت تجذب لنا
السياحه وتعطينا شيئا نتحد خلفه
متزايده عندما يدرك الناس انه ملك جيد
ولكن امامه تحدي كبير للوصول الى ما حظيت
به الملكه الراحله من شعبيه هناك الكثير
مما يعشقونه بالفعل وهو من دعاه حمايه
البيئه وانا متاكده من انه مع استمرار
حكمه سوف تتزايد شعبيته مع العلم انه ليس
كل شخص داع للملكيه فهناك 20% تقريبا
غالبيتهم من جيل الشباب لا يهتمون
بالملكيه
وان ترك رحيل الملكه تساؤلات بشان اداء
النظام الملكي من دونها في مجتمع متنوع
ودينميكي بشكل متزايد الا ان استطلاعا
حديثا لشركه يشير الى دعم المؤسسه الملكيه
بثمانيه وخمسين في المئه مما يمثل
التراجعا بعشره
بعهد الملكه علاقه الامير اندرو بالجفر
ابستان المداني بجرائم جنسيه وكشف الامير
هاري بخلافاته المثيره للجدل مع شقيقه
ويليام ووالده الملك تشارلز اضرت بسمعه
العائله المالكه مما زاد من دعاه
الجمهوريه في بريطانيا ان الملكيه التي
يعود تاريخها الى الف سنه لا مكان لها في
الديمقراطيه الحديثه
الملك تشارج الثالث لكنه لم يرث احترام
شريحه من المجتمع دعمت والدته وان كانت
العائله المالكه لا تزال تحظى بتاييد جزء
كبير من البريطانيين لما لهذا النظام
الملكي من ارتباط بالتقاليد والاستقرار
ومكانه بعض افراد العائله الملكيه في قلوب
الناس مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات